avant mon invité était plutôt du genre
rapportèrent une tenue de
radioprotection avec un compteur Giger à
la main depuis qu'elle s'est lancé en
politique c'est aussi elle qu'on envoie
en première ligne quand il faut éteindre
un incendie
[Musique]
bonjour mode braise bonjour Alors je le
disais en quelques mots en lancement
avant la politique vous occupiez un
poste un peu particulier chez EDF vous
êtes intervenu notamment en situation de
crise à Saint-Martin après le passage de
l'ouragan Irma pour rétablir le courant
sur place mais ça c'était pas
l'essentiel de votre travail de votre
mission chez EDF non l'essentiel de ma
mission et c'était mon premier poste
c'est comment vous faites en cas
d'accident grave une tempête un ouragan
un tremblement de terre pour réanimer
réalimenté par non la centrale en eau en
air et en électricité donc faire en
sorte que il n'y ait pas de fonte du
cœur tout simplement du coeur d'une
centrale nucléaire parce que là vous
parlez de centrale nucléaire de
catastrophe nucléaire c'est c'était une
unité d'intervention qui a été créée
après Fukushima après Fukushima on s'est
rendu compte que les moyens qui étaient
disponibles sur la centrale s'il y avait
eu un gros accident
fallait pas nécessairement compter
dessus et en capacité d'en amener de
l'extérieur donc vous deviez monter une
cellule de crise à quelques kilomètres
de la centrale c'est comment est-ce que
vous montez un poste de commandement
comment est-ce que vous faites venir des
équipes de l'extérieur d'autres
centrales comment est-ce que vous
acheminez du matériel et puis comment
est-ce que vous réalimentez les diesels
d'ultime secours en carburant comment
est-ce que vous maintenez à bonne
pression de réacteur comment est-ce que
vous remettez de l'eau dedans pour le
refroidir tout simplement il faut aimer
le risque pour faire ce genre de métier
faut aimer le risque faut aimer la
découverte déjà parce que moi c'était
une découverte le monde du nucléaire je
le connaissais pas du tout faut aimer le
contact humain parce que c'est un vrai
travail d'équipe la gestion de crise
avec les techniciens avec les préf avec
les pouvoirs publics de façon plus
générale
moi j'ai beaucoup appris parce que il y
a à la fois des compétences techniques
sur comment fonctionne une centrale
nucléaire comment est-ce que
fonctionnent les différents matériels
donc vous avez besoin et puis comment
vous intervenez en gestion de crise vous
n'êtes pas dans du management dans du
management vous êtes dans du
commandement et d'ailleurs on travaille
beaucoup notamment avec le monde des
armées qui nous a aidé là-dessus parce
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'intervention en
situation déstructurée donc vous avez
fait des études d'ingénieur pour exercer
ce métier mais c'est pas ce que vous
vouliez faire à l'origine vous étiez
plutôt attiré par les sciences
politiques pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
renoncé à cela alors moi je suis issu
d'une famille on a toujours beaucoup
parlé politique à la maison on a
toujours beaucoup débattues mes parents
n'en faisaient pas mais ici intéressait
donc c'était très présent à table j'ai
eu effectivement envie de faire des
sciences politiques alors à l'époque
qu'on est au lycée on pense à Sciences
Po et mais en fait je suis une famille
aussi on m'a toujours dit l'important
c'était la sécurité de l'emploi
une famille plutôt modeste mon papa a
connu des périodes de chômage dans sa
vie
pour être sûr d'avoir un job que vous a
dit faites plutôt que plutôt des
ingénieurs
tu auras toujours du travail c'est la
sécurité de l'emploi et donc au fond
pour moi qui était bonne en maths
c'était à la fois la maîtrise du risque
et la garantie simplement d'avoir un
avenir professionnel stable alors ça
vous a pas empêché de garder un oeil sur
la politique pendant longtemps avec une
orientation plutôt à droite mais votre
première engagement politique c'est en
2017 comme militante pour Emmanuel
Macron dans sa campagne présidentielle
ensuite vous êtes devenu référente dans
marche dans les Hauts-de-Seine puis tête
de liste au municipales à Levallois
est-ce que vous avez pas un peu chercher
à chasser le naturel cette attirance
vers la politique et est-ce que la
politique est pas revenue un peu au
galop dans votre vie je dirais pas que
j'ai cherché à la chasser parce que
quand même durant je me rappelle durant
ma prépa à Paris je regardais et c'est
pas une blague je regardez LCP je me
rappelle très bien sur mon petit poste
de télé qui a dit qu'à l'époque et
effectivement c'est revenu alors c'est
revenu parce que c'était une période de
ma vie où j'étais installée
professionnellement et donc j'avais du
temps elle est important et puis parce
que parce que Emmanuel Macron tout
simplement on a l'impression que vous
avez été un peu happé par la politique
comme si ça venait répondre à un besoin
qui était pas tout à fait comblé en vous
peut-être par votre job c'est un besoin
c'est un besoin d'engagement il y a
quand même un lien entre le travail qui
était le mien chez EDF et celui qui
aujourd'hui mis en politique c'est la
notion de service public et c'est la
notion de service à l'autre
EDF le service public de l'électricité
c'est les hommes en bleu qui sont venus
vous réalimenter le soir de la tempête
de 99 c'est ceux qui montent au poteau
et qui font en sorte que vous puissiez
avoir de l'électricité quand vous
branchez votre téléphone le besoin
d'avoir du sens dans votre travail dans
votre action quotidienne ça c'est en
tout cas peut-être que le plus petit
dénominateur commun entre les deux c'est
que ce sont des missions dans lesquelles
on donne pour les autres et dans
lesquels le service public l'intérêt
général ça à sa place autre date
importante ensuite dans votre engagement
politique c'est octobre 2020 c'est une
nouvelle étape là la République en
marche décide de nommer deux femmes
venues de la société civile pour
m'occuper les fonctions de porte-parole
et là vous décidez de tenter votre
chance parmi de nombreuses candidates et
le résultat ça donne ça
je m'appelle Maud Bregeon j'ai 29 ans je
suis ingénieur dans le domaine de
l'énergie spécialisée en gestion de
crise
[Musique]
parce que c'était un processus qui a été
transparent avec des règles claires et
connues de tous parce que ça montre
encore une fois on est un mouvement qui
s'ouvre largement à la société civile et
parce qu'on est un mouvement qui prône
la parité et qui se l'applique d'abord à
soi-même vous l'évoquez brièvement dans
cette vidéo mais vous avez franchi les
étapes d'un casting qui était quand même
digne de la Star Ac sauf que là c'était
pour devenir porte-parole oui en fait
c'était de la star
on sélectionné puis écrémé petit à petit
il y a eu d'abord une vidéo qu'on a dû
envoyer pour se présenter montrer un peu
comment est-ce qu'on parlait devant une
caméra et puis ensuite plusieurs étapes
effectivement de sélections
qui vous poseraient des questions format
un peu grand jury et donc il y a eu
plusieurs étapes successives et
effectivement c'est comme ça que c'est
comme ça que j'ai été recruté je crois
que c'était extrêmement important en
fait dans cette étape c'est que la
République en marche qui n'a pas tout
réussi par ailleurs mais démontre là
quelque chose important c'est qu'elle a
eu cette volonté jusqu'au bout de faire
monter des jeunes issus de la société
civile qui n'avait pas fait de politique
moi je me rappelle une amie à moi
Aurélie taquilin qui est lui a
Courbevoie m'avait dit qu'il venait de
chez elle m'avait dit à l'époque tu sais
nous chez LR où elle lui MP à l'époque
on prenait notre ticket puis on
attendait 25 ans
vous avez été propulsé comme ça dans des
fonctions
c'est d'arriver à mettre sur le devant
de la scène des gens qui au fond dans la
logique qui était celle de ce qu'on
appelle l'ancien monde n'aurait pas dû y
être et alors pendant longtemps vous
avez été donc porte-parole du parti de
la majorité présidentielle en restant
salarié de DF le jour vous avez mené une
double vie en quelque sorte parce que le
soir vous deviez aller sur les sur les
plateaux télé pour défendre l'action de
la majorité comment vous avez survécu à
ça
euh au prix de une bonne partie de ma
vie personnelle j'imagine que vous avez
compris
c'est un une mission bénévole donc il
faut bien continuer à payer le loyer et
les factures ce qui est difficile au
fond c'est la gymnastique mentale que ça
demande c'est à dire la journée vous
occupez des centrales nucléaires du
nucléaire et de la production
d'électricité entre midi et deux vous
allez parler du covid sur BFMTV puis
vous revenez à votre travail et le soir
vous repartez parler d'immigration et de
sécurité je crois que la clé c'est le
travail en fait la clé c'est le travail
moi je me souviens quand j'ai été nommé
on m'a donné plusieurs conseils le
premier c'était Gérald Darmanin qui m'a
dit tu prends un ou deux dossiers et tu
les travailles à fond et le deuxième
conseil qu'on m'a donné c'est qu'on
continue à parler comme les gens et
finalement soit qui tu es communique
simplement et je pense que
l'authenticité c'est important et que le
fait de venir de la société civile
peut-être que ça le permet en partie pas
uniquement les gens qu'on fait que de la
politique le sont aussi parfois c'était
la question que j'allais vous poser là
vous y avez presque répondu mais on vous
a formé on vous a donné des conseils
avant de vous envoyer comme ça sur les
plateaux des chaînes info face à des
adversaires politiques aguerris des
journalistes politiques
chercher la petite bête derrière déjà et
qui nous a entraînés à la communication
en médias pour commencer quelques heures
ensuite on apprend quand même beaucoup
sur le tas comment est-ce qu'on est sur
un plateau la façon dont on s'exprime ça
tient déjà beaucoup de qui on est
nous-mêmes et puis ensuite encore une
fois ça tient sur le travail qu'on qu'on
abat moi on ne va pas en plateau sans
faire railler les dossiers on ne parle
pas de sujets sans connaître les
chiffres sans avoir un petit peu mûri
notre réflexion l'objectif c'est quand
même de pas être des machines à faire
des contrôles contrôler d'éléments de
langage et pour ça c'est nécessite
d'avoir une réflexion aussi un peu
personnelle sur les choses moi c'est
toujours ce que j'ai essayé de faire
d'avoir cette approche qui mienne qui
tient à mon vécu et encore une fois je
crois que les gens il cherche la
sincérité ils sont pas forcément
d'accord avec vous mais l'important
c'est d'être sincère et qu'on est
sincère ça se voit quelques semaines à
peine après votre nomination vous êtes
retrouvé face à Florian Philippot sur le
plateau de cnews je vous vois rire et là
vous avez sorti une série de punchline
comme on dit ça fait le tour du web je
crois que le petit extrait que vous avez
posté on est à 1 million 800000 vues sur
Twitter on va on va le regarder qui peut
d'humilité quand on est au pouvoir
aujourd'hui la dernière fois que vous
êtes présenté à des élections aux
européennes vous avez fait 0,65% c'est
moins que le partiel réaliste alors
qu'ils avaient mis un chien sur leur
affiche pas moi j'ai eu le mérite d'y
aller madame et vous vous avez fait quoi
sur votre vie
vous avez fait quoi madame vous défendez
quoi comme conversion parce que là
depuis ce matin je ne fais
dans votre vie dans votre arc monsieur
pas médecin excusez-moi je suis fils
d'instituteur vous les aviez préparés
ces formules où elles sont sorties comme
ça
la toute première j'y avais pensé avant
celle sur le score aux européennes et le
reste non on vient naturellement du fait
de l'échange ce qui est drôle en fait
c'est que je ne sais pas si je le ferai
aujourd'hui ah bon
enfin il fallait quand même avoir un
certain aplomb et de rester soi-même
naturel vous dites que vous le referiez
pas aujourd'hui c'est donc vous êtes
formaté maintenant alors je pense qu'on
se formate forcément un peu avec le
temps faut essayer de lutter contre ça
non mais il y a une sacrée dose de
provocation
j'essaie peut-être aujourd'hui d'être un
peu moins
voilà d'être un peu moins dans la
provocation mais peut-être que l'époque
est comme ça aussi on est dans une
période politique et sociétale qui est
compliquée donc j'essaie davantage
aujourd'hui de
d'adoucir et d'essayer de voilà de
rechercher davantage à consensus plutôt
que des provocations on parlait du goût
du risque à propos de votre premier
métier chez chez EDF est-ce qu'on
retrouve pas un peu ce goût du risque
dans ses fonctions de porte-parole quand
on est voilà comme ça face à des
adversaires sans trop savoir où on va
aller je crois que ça tient aussi de mon
caractère personnel moi j'ai toujours
été
bagareuse j'ai toujours eu un
franc-parler je me suis toujours j'ai
toujours beaucoup été amené à m'exprimer
d'ailleurs je me souviens quand j'étais
petite mes parents me demandais beaucoup
mon avis j'étais écouté
ça vient aussi beaucoup d'éducation
c'est l'heure de notre quiz à présent un
quiz spécial porte-parole trois petites
questions trois réponses rapides on
commence quel journaliste redoutez-vous
le plus en interview politique
ça vient pas naturellement la réponse
j'ai peur de personne c'est des pompes
plutôt des contextes que des
journalistes j'ai fait à Pauline de
Malherbe en début de semaine je trouve
quand même qu'elle tient redoutablement
et quel adversaire politique justement
est le plus coriace je sais pas ça
dépend des moments moi je trouve qu'avec
une réponse quand même
c'est le RN au fond on a des divergences
qui sont tellement flagrantes et qui
sont tellement visibles que
le téléspectateur à mon avis se fait
assez facilement une opinion sur ce que
dit l'un et l'autre enfin pour 2027 vous
êtes plutôt Bruno Le Maire Gérald
Darmanin ou Édouard Philippe je veux pas
de langue de bois Emmanuel Macron
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est en train de faire passer une
réforme des retraites là je crois que et
puis moi je fais de la politique depuis
pas très longtemps je sais même pas si
j'en ferai en 2027 honnêtement moi j'en
sais rien on suivra ça
bon merci beaucoup bonne raison d'être
venu dans la politique et moi
[Musique]